to learn languages ​​we have to
master the basics it's true not
breaking news it is not possible to master the
basics especially at the beginning We are going to
continue making the same mistakes
for a long time So we have to
not worry about this useless
will to master the basics What  It is the
basics and I say it from my experience
as a language learner, no What are the
basics the words for example
basic words What are the basic words there are
many books that teach languages
start with I don't know the colors the
numbers but those things are very
difficult there are words with more
frequency but in any case we are going to
find these words with high
frequency So we are going to learn those
words more easily but certain
words are still going to be difficult to
remember those words no And the same
thing for eh structures for me for
example  Now I'm speaking in Spanish, I
don't do much, so I'm going to make
basic mistakes, but if I speak more,
I'd make less basic mistakes, no.
So basic is a very
subjective concept and in any case, there is a
natural order of acquiring a
language according to what you study and what they have done.  for
example Steven crashen and this
natural order of acquisition can depend
on the language we are learning from
our language to us for example an
Italian who is learning Spanish
Well it will be easier Eh many things about
grammar and also the words are
similar to words or structures  in
Italian then there is a natural order
that is different But for someone who
is learning, for example, English, eh, we
all know that in English the
third person of the present tense has an es,
for example I go you go he goes but
this one is very difficult, it's one thing
basic grammatical but Non-natives
continue to make this very
simple mistake because we have to build
new habits and this is done according to a
Natural order and it is done throughout not
deliberately trying to learn to
master the basics is useless and does not help
because all the  The time we are
trying to learn, for example, the
conjugations, is time that I am not going to
use to listen more, read more,
speak more, so that my brain gets
used to the new language and for that
reason, in link For example, I always
start with the mini-stories that are
easy with a lot of repetition and in this
way an idea of ​​the language is created
because finally we can focus on
the basics after we have an idea
of ​​the language and we can finally after
a lot of experience with the language
try to perfect if not
master because  we are going to continue to
make mistakes it is very important not to
have a feeling of frustration And if
after a long time we are
making basic mistakes because this
is the case it is the case with me uh I think it is
the case for most people who
learn languages ​​then  The most important thing
is to stay active, keep listening,
reading, enjoying the language and little by little you
will improve and if later you want to
concentrate on certain aspects of
vocabulary or grammar you can
do so and it would be easier to assimilate those
things, explanations, patterns because
in the end the foundation of the language is not
It's like building a house with bricks,
it's not like there's a foundation and
then we're going to build the second
floor, the third floor, it's not like a plate of
gelatin, things come and go,
we learn and forget, and that's
why in link we don't measure the
Student progress not because this is
difficult sometimes we have the
impression of progressing and then not but
what we can measure eh And the most
important thing is the level of activity of
each one if the learner continues
active listening reading over time
passing with  the language with a
positive attitude is sure to progress.
So my advice as a person who
has learned many languages ​​at different levels
is that we cannot master the basic things, we
have to continue
studying, cook, read interesting things
and little by little we will  get used
to the new language without bothering with this
desire to master the basics until
later